Gilbert vous continuez hein plus que
jamais à vivre finalement comme si vous
n'aviez pas de handicap comme un
voyant bonsoir tous les deux bonsoir
Gilbert montagier
bonsoir Nicole vous semblez bien vous
amusé hein ensemble et travailler ouais
il est sacrément taquin he oui oui oui
puis c'était c'était tout à fait juste
ce que les amis ont dit de Gilbert et
voilà je t'ai un peu retrouvé aussi oh
mais me t'cline aussi beaucoup et je
suis obligé de pas me laisser faire
parce que avec la personnalité de Madame
sinon on est foutu la tien est pas
triste non
plus c'est vrai une sacrée personnalité
l'un et l'autre oui on est deux
capricornesou mais comment justement on
conjugue la vie privée et la vie
professionnel puisque vous êtes devenu
son manager je sais que vous n'aimez pas
le mot pré quoi ça n'existe quasiment
plus je sais pas il se trouve que petit
à petit he tu as réussi à m'enrôler
c'est vous qui avez voulu oui ouais
parce que j'ai j'ai j'ai ressenti très
vite les qualités de Nicole les qualités
rigoristes les qualités discipline enfin
tout tout ce que tout tout ce que j'aime
pas trop faire quoi en fait alors facile
facile ouais mais c'est vrai c'est ce
qui vous a séduit chez elle avant toute
chose Gilbert pas avant toute chose ah
non avant toute chose c'est c'est c'est
ça féminité c'est sa sa finesse c'est
son intelligence son intelligence
d'esprit je vais placer quand même son
intelligence
d'esprit heureusement que M nous réunit
parce que finalement jamais j'entends
genre de chois bien sûr fait pour ça les
émissions je sais très doué mire je me
suis dit attends c'est une bonne
émission pour nous c'est mais parce que
au bout de 17 ans on oublie les
déclarations
d'amour non mais non mais des fois elle
est un peu malentendante pas sa
faute et Nicole qu'est-ce qui vous av
vous
séduite c'est l'être complètement
différent je je vais je vais me lancer
mireil parce que je suis très bien ici
mais on y va on y va lorsque l'on a eu
un passé un petit peu difficile enfin un
moment dans dans dans mon passé quelque
peu difficile on a pas forcément envie
de recomposer avec du genre humain
traditionnel entre guillemets et la
sensibilité dû au fait que Gilbert est
non voyant a été pour moi un atout
considérable et et par conséquent
c'était l'être qu'il fallait après mon
divorce c'est-à-dire que loin justement
de vous effrayer parce que le handicap
aurait pu vous faire peur il fallait le
surmonter au contraire pour vous c'était
un atout absolument et comment vous
l'imaginez Nicole comment vous la voyez
vous Gilbert je l'imagine exactement
comme elle est c'estàd que mais par
contre c'est vrai que je ne il y a des
choses auxquelles je ne pense pas les
couleurs par exemple il faut que je me
force à penser à la couleur de ses
cheveux euh je sais qu'il y a du il y a
du rouge ça tu peu de vert et de bleu
non non il pas de vert bleu enfin non
mais je suis sûr que vos couleurs sont
très belles mais ce n'est pas parce que
je les sous-estime mais c'est parce que
je je ne suis pas programmé comme ça les
couleurs je connais pas je connais les
mots ouais mais je connais pas ce que
c'est et les sensations et les
sensations ça ça oui ça parle plus
évidemment non c'est vrai il a on a je
trouve enfin moi je trouve que j'ai j'ai
une certaine facilité à la à la
sensualité je ve dire chacun l'a mais
mais je trouve que mon mode de vision
devrait me rapprocher de de ce critère
là ben oui c'est tactile automatiquement
tactile et puis et puis tout ce qui
passe par l'esprit moi je trouve qu'il y
a rien de plus beau que par exemple sans
toucher une main je veux dire juste
d'être comme ça tout près de la main et
là il y a tout le royaume de
l'anticipation qui s'ouvre et qui dit
waouh qu'est-ce que ça va être beau
quand je vais lui toucher la main ben tu
dis tout ça bah oui je dis ça va
vite c'est extraordinaire ou oui c'est
il parle de finalement de sensualité
d'érotisme sûr bien sûr mais Nicole je
peux me permettre de vous demander
puisque c'est vous qui en avez parlé
vous dites j'ai vécu des choses dures et
finalement j'étais bien dans cette
univers là l'univers de de Gilbert et
des nonvoyants je peux vous demander ce
que vous avez vécu oui c'est vrai que un
divorce n'est jamais
facile pour tout le monde femme ou homme
et oui parce que vous étiez marié
aussiilbert ah ou ben moi aussi j'ai ça
pas été facile du tout et lorsqu'on a
des enfants aussi les choses prennent
une dimension et bien extraordinaire et
et oui on est meurtri souvent plusieurs
années et il a fallu l'oreille l'écoute
et la présence de Gilbert pour faire que
les choses et bien aillent mieux je
crois qu'à la fin de cette
émission j'ai
faitevenenir bon on se demandait si on
allait voir un psy finalement ce j voilà
plus besoin mais c'est pour ça que vous
êtes à ce point fusionnel je pense que
ça contribu bien sûr bien c'est par nos
personnalités on
AF on aime beaucoup être l'un avec
l'autre alors vous êtes tellement proche
que même en 80 18 je crois vous avez
chanté ensemble mon Dieu mon Dieu pour
un duo mémorable c'est vrai dans nos
têtes oui on
écoute mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
le
soleil dis-moi où irait mon
bateau sans le petit capitaine qui est
sur la
photo si tu te souviens des mot d'On va
s'aimer si tu te souviens quand on s'est
rencontré je peux pas les imaginer l'un
sans l'autre c'est impossible ils sont
ils sont tellement fusionnels et
tellement tout ensemble à partager et je
pense que jamais jamais ils se
sépareront ils ont eu une autre vie
avant ils savent ce qu'ils sont fait en
se remariant et je pense qu'ils iront
jusqu'à la fin de leur vie ensemble si
tu te souviens
Dei pris la main tu m'as dit viens
danser et je me souviens quand tu m'as
emassé ça je
m wouh c'est c'est plus qu'une chanson
c'est une déclaration d'amour ça a
commencé un dimanche matin Mireille
j'étais au clavier et puis j'ai eu envie
d'écrire cette mélodie et le Didier
barbolivien qu'on embrasse nous a écrit
le texte et on s'est bien amusé en tout
cas on on l'avait vraiment fait en plus
sans autres but que pour
ça vous n'avez pas décidé une carrière
de chanteuse après d'école non pas du
tout moi j'ai pas décidé de faire une
carrière de photographe non plus donc
tout va bien qui d'illeurs bien que bien
que et votre ami a raison jamais vous ne
vous séparerez il nous connaît bien ben
je pense qu'on a on a tout
à à gagner à être ensemble est-ce que
c'est vrai que vos deux enfants que vous
avez eu donc chacun de votre côté se
sont mariés c'est incroyable euh Cécile
la fille de une école donc qui était ma
belle-fille
euh ben un jour on a découvert que avec
Éric mon fils il il s'aimait vraiment
d'un d'un amour réel et et ils sont
mariés et ça jamais j'aurais pu imaginer
un truc comme ça moi pourtant j'ai
l'imagination assez fertile hein mais
c'était incroyable et pour vous dire que
à tel point il fallait que l'on soit
ensemble pour que nos enfants se
rencontrent c'est ce qu'on se dit c'est
ce qu'on dit SR et en même temps c'est
une réponse justement à l'écl de la
famille que vous avez vécu là pour le
coup ah oui ou oui oui c'est comme si
que la boucle était bouclée finalement
elle était resserrée à tout jamais alors
Gilbert vous continuez hein plus que
jamais à vivre finalement comme si vous
n'aviez pas de handicap comme un voyant
à prendre des risques à vous lancer des
défis moi depuis le début de ma vie j'ai
jamais considéré le fait que j'étais
aveugle comme un handicap pour moi ce
qui était un handicap c'est que le monde
était pas préparé pour moi du tout et
que il avait pas l'air le monde de de de
savoir que que je voulais entrer dans le
monde quoi c'était ça l'handicap donc
moi ça jamais été un problème je veux
dire j'ai su que je voyais pas enfin
comme on dit vulgairement qu je voyais
pas clair alors que c'est des conneries
parce que moi je trouve que je vois
assez clair mais que je voyais pas avec
mes yeux bon ben ça m'a jamais empêché
de dormir c'est le cas de le dire mais
vous faites tout j'ai envie de dire
puisque vous avez piloté donc un
hélicoptère ah oui je me transforme en
pilote automatique moi c'est-à-dire que
je suis les instructions ça c'est un
écureuil sans les noisettes mais enfin
bon j'ai piloté on vous a vu conduire
une voiture à 160 km/ he ouais ça
c'était un un grand grand flash pour moi
parce que c'est c'est effectivement le
seule chose qui me manque dans ma vie
c'est de
pouvoir je suis très sérieux là de
pouvoir pouvoir prendre ma voiture
pouvoir dire à Nicole je t'emmène parce
que certes c'est ma voiture enfin c'est
notre voiture mais c'est elle qui
conduit ça m'enuie un peu ça m'embête un
peu que c'est soit toujours elle conduit
c'est cette indépendance là qui vous
manque oui c'est vrai de de de d'avoir
le vous savez en fait je crois que le le
le le plus gros des handicaps c'est de
ne pas avoir le choix c'est ça un vrai
handicap mais ce que j'aimerais si la
voiture avec intelligence artificielle
c'est en train d'arriver m avant 10 ans
on l'aura c'està-dire qu'on on on on
indua la voiture le la donnée de de de
du point d'arrivée et la voiture vous
emmènera toute seule moi je ferai
confiance à une voiture comme ça Nicole
parfois vous trouvez qu'il est trop
cassecou vous lui interdisez certaines
choses vous avez peur pour lui son envie
d'aller au devant des choses est
tellement importantes que de toute façon
on ne peut qu'urler à côté et ça passe
mais tu ne pourrais pas m'arrêter voilà
ça peut faire flipper un petit peu mais
non je ou elle eu peur quand même Nicole
le jour où elle le dit pas le jour où où
j'ai conduit le TGV qu'elle était dans
la locomotive avec
tu m'as dit tu très peur je trouvais que
c'était dingue de te laisser moi je ris
je ris bêtement croyant que c'est faux
non mais j'ai trouvais que c'était Ding
quand- que vous avez fait ça on fait
deux fois vous allez rassurer tout le
monde ils vont avoir peur la prochaine
fois pr le TGV en se disant Gilbert est
au commande on m'a proposé justement de
faire l'annonce et je dis mais non ça va
faire peur à tout le monde c'est pas la
peine en plus c'était le TGV on dirait
un train pour aveugle parce que il y a
des signaux partout vra mais vraiment et
donc la vitesse la vitesse les vitesses
sont préprogrammées de par le le
terminal de départ donc il y a pas de
problème il faut innover justement dans
l'emploi et je je je je prétends pas que
il faudrait engager que des que des que
des chauffeurs non voyant c'est pas ça
mais pas que ce pas que cel mais ou
de alors vous avez vécu une autre
aventure tout à fait extraordinaire avec
Frédéric Lopez vous êtes parti l'année
dernière dans l'Himalaya pour son
émission rendez-vous en TER inconnu ah
ouais une expérience de vie mais
incroyable incroyable moi j'ai j'ai fait
des trucs que j'avais jamais fait de ma
vie on me dit voilà on va on va on va
entamer une chevauchée ben je dis s'il
faut entamer une chevauchée entamons une
chevauchée hein oui mais enfin personne
ne vous y oblige c'était vous étiez
partant pour tout absolument alors j'ai
eu des peurs quand même bien sûr bien
sûr c'était tellement étroit les chemin
quand on quand on était sur le le cheval
que je savais très bien que s'il y avait
un faux mouvement on pouvait avit
vraiment basculer quoi puis la rencontre
avec avec dolma la maman et puis ça m'a
surpris qu'elle qu'elle éclaté en
sanglot quand elle a appris que j'étais
aveugle quoi parce que moi je
m'attendais pas à ça du tout alors comme
d'habitude dans ma vie vous avez vu ce
que j'ai fait ben je l'ai rassuré voilà
c'est ça que je fais et vous ne
comprenez pas pourquoi c c l' trristé
ben non parce que pour moi je trouve
qu'il y a rien de triste du tout hein
mais je pense que c'est c'est au-delà de
la tristesse c'est dans une autre
culture aussi c'était voilà trop fort
j'aurais dû l'écrire à l'avance c'est
sûr dans quelle
langue Nicole alors pour une fois vous
n'étiez pas du voyage non non mon cœur
était pas loin mais mais moi ça m'a moi
j'aime bien aussi alors m puis que
j'aime bien aussi moi avoir des moments
aussi de de de solitude quand on est
seul enfin moi je vais parler pour moi
quand je suis seul en tant que moi
Gilbert
nonvoyant je fonctionne beaucoup mieux
sur mes sens mes critères à moi c'estàd
que quand on est avec quelqu'un on ne
fonctionne pas pareil parce qu'on n pas
à être aussi en éveil sur tout puisqu'on
sait intrinsèquement qu'on est avec la
personne qu'on aime en plus donc c'est
pas pareil mais quand je suis tout seul
je suis obligé je suis obligé de de me
débrouiller je suis obligé de vous aimez
ça depuis toujours de toute façon je
pense que c'est je pense que c'est une
c'est pas indépendance qu'il faut qu'il
garde bien sûr que vous avez depuis
l'enfance oui oui j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des parents qui étaient hyper
combatifs et très ouverts qui m'ont pas
il jamais créé de surhicap parce qu'en
fait c'est ça le problème ils nous ont
pas surprotégé c'est ça que voulais dire
voà oui oui mais ça aurait créé un
surhandicap on aperçoit ton papa et ta
maman en photo ah voilà c'est joli de
voir d'ailleurs comment vous commentez
Nicole oui c'est votre père et votre
mère qui sont en photo sur l'écran et
oui maintenant il n'existe plus qu'en
photo mais mais en fait les meilleures
photos c'est c'est dans la tête bien sûr
mais ils m'ont donné la la clé des
portes du possible voilà tout simplement
c'est énorme bah oui ou oui une famille
modeste he ah oui ça oui très modeste
enfants on vivait dans 43 m²r mais ça
allait bien quoi on avait assez à manger
et à quel moment à quel moment Gilbert
vous êtes dit que finalement vous
vouliez faire de la musique et chanter
alors à quel momentors très tôt parce
que donc j'ai commencé piano j'avais 5
ans ma musique classique bon ah le piano
à 5 ans quand même ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts vos parents phot de oui éident
quand il y a pas beaucoup de moyens de
faire du piano ah bah surtout qu'on
avait acheté 25000 anciens francs et le
problème c'est qu'on avait pas de blé
évidemment pour le déménagement donc
c'est mon père et mon frère qui ont
porté ce piano pendant CIN étages sur
leur dos et mon père a cassé la cheminée
l'unique cheminée qu'on avait dans la
chambre à coucher pour pour pour que le
piano puisse passer quoi al sur cette
photo tu portes un casque et pendant
longtemps je dis pourquoi Gilbert a un
casque pour jouer du pian c'est vrai
c'est vrai et j'ai appris que c'était un
un costume de de de gendarme oui de
est-ce que je sais plus ce que c'était
un costume que j'avais eu pour noël j'ai
jamais réussi à le voir ce Père Noël
c'est truc incroyable j'arrivais il
était déjà parti bon d'accord mais mais
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup aimé mon
enfance dans le quartier rue des
Pyrénées tout ça j'étais déjà très connu
parce que j'étais le petit qui voit pas
clair les gens disent ah c'est le petit
qui voit pas clair et moi j'aimais ça ça
me dérangeait pas pour revenir à votre
carrière Gilbert vous saviez que ça
marcherait vous étiez sûr que ça
marcherait ou pas du tout moi je me
voyais musicien en fait je me voyais
musicien pourant le matos sur scène
j'avais compris que c'était quand même
un vecteur pour avoir la la la porte du
cœur des jeunes filles qui s'ouvraient
peut-être je me disais que c'était
peut-être un un bon truc ça et puis bon
puis j'aimais bien jouer donc je me
forçais pas alors mais je me voyais pas
chanteur et avoir un succès aussi
colossal que celui he du début des
années
70 c'est vrai qu'au début c'était
compliqué pour vous vous étiez souvent
blessé parce que vous chantiez et qu'il
n'y avait pas d'entretien voilà c'est
bien vous parliez de ça parce que il y a
pas longtemps que que je commence à me à
me l'admettre ça c'est marrant j'y
pensais pas pendant des années mais
c'est vrai que au début moi ce qui m'a
vraiment fait du de la peine c'est que
alors bon on étais content que je viens
de chanter la chanson mais les autres
artistes voyant ils avaient la partie
interview et moi non moi non c'était bye
bye c'était fini mais c'est un peu de ma
faute c'est-à-dire que j'aurais dû avoir
la force mais à 20 ans c'est difficile
de m'imposer et de dire
attendez moi aussi je veux parler moi
aussi j'ai peut-être des trucs à dire et
alors après quand ça a commencé à se
débloquer dès qu'on m'a donné un petit
peu la parole j'ai commencé à parler des
solutions pour les personnes handicapées
alors là ça passait pas parce qu'à
l'époque comprends à l'époque il voulait
pas trop entendre parler de ça
heureusement maintenant les les les
consciences sont vraiment ouverte et et
heureusement c'est ça qui a évolué qui
permis certaines choses c'est vrai que
vous avez écrit la mélodie de cette
chanson vous inspirant d'un champ
d'oiseaux c'est la légende ça non non
non non c'est totalement vrai j'ai écris
la mélodie the FO 4 ans avant
l'enregistrement j'avais à peu près donc
16 ans j'étais sur mon petit chemin sur
la commune de Saint-Léon dans l'Allier
et j'ai entendu un petit oiseau
effectivement je suis partie des quatre
notes de cet oiseau j'ai trouvé que
c'était beau donc ça devait sûrement
arriver et comment donc on on vit le
succès ce succès là si rapide ben moi je
le vivais très bien moi je j'ai quand
même une qualité c'est je sais m'adapter
à toutes sortes de situations j'aime les
gens quoi j'aime les gens on a la chance
de jouer pour pour pour souvent je
répète ça mais c'est vrai moi je joue à
la fois pour les policiers pour les
voleurs je joue pour tout le monde je
joue pour tout le monde l'important
c'est que ce sont des êtres humains tous
différents et tous importants l'autre
jour j'étais en en prison en anterre
pour jouer je suis ressorti après mais
mais je suis allé parce que je fais ça
de temps en temps je trouve que c'est
normal de de on peut pas faire que ça
mais d'aller dans les endroits où la
musique a du mal à entrer c'est c'est la
façon de remercier d'être publ voilà
c'est ce que je pense qui alors on
connaissait Gilbert montagier musicien
chanteur maintenant il y a l'homme
engagé puisque depuis 2007 oui vous avez
été chargé de conduire la mission du
handicap et puis après ça ça a poursuivi
avec avec ma nomination en tant que
secrétaire national chargé de l'handicap
on regarde ce reportage puisque vous
avez pris cette mission très au sérieux
bah oui bien
sûr en mars 2009 Xavier Bertrand le
secrétaire général de l'UMP nommait
Gilbert montagier secrétaire national
chargé du handicap au sein du mouvement
populaire une nomination qui à l'époque
a fait débat je nomme deux personnes en
même temps David Douillet et Gilbert
montager aussitôt c'est ah ça y est le
MP est ce que le P veut dire populaire
il veut dire il veut dire populaire
parce que Gilbert est comme cela ça été
celui qui a reçu un maximum de courriers
pas d'admirateur pas de fans de personne
handicapé voilà mon problème aidez-moi
Gilbert avait déjà rendu un rapport à
Xavier Bertrand alors ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la solidarité
en 2007 une mission qui avait permis des
avancées très concrètes pour
l'accessibilité des handicapés au
transport en commun par exemple sur
l'autom
DEP vous pouvez naviguer dans les
différents
menus des quatre coins de l'écran très
bien appuyz en bas à droite plein d'Ar
il a compris que ce mot pouvoir bah
c'est surtout le verbe qui est
intéressant pouvoir faire bouger pouvoir
faire vibrer pouvoir justement fa faire
aimer les mêmes choses que que que les
les objectifs les défis qu'on partage
Gilbert c'est un homme de défi je vous
remercie infiniment et présent à de
nombreux colloques au conféren Gilbert
Montagner s'implique sans compter depuis
plus d'un an dans ses nouvelles
fonctions en fait en deux mots comme en
a le sujet de de l'handicap en France
doit être considéré comme un sujet
majeur et prioritaire parce que si on
fait pas ça on handicap tout de suite le
sujet et on le rend
marginal alors c'est vrai que ça me
passionne ça me passionne qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je veux moi je je veux que
toute personne handicapée qui ne peut
pas travailler qui qui n'est pas en
mesure de pouvoir travailler et il y en
a plein soit au moins apte à être au
niveau au moins du seuil de pauvreté ce
qui n'est pas le cas et ça me ça me fait
beaucoup de peine en ce moment ça c'est
ça la priorité pour moi ouais pour moi
oui et puis mais la même priorité aussi
est que ceux qui peuvent
travailler que les employeurs qui nous
regardent ne considèrent pas que
d'engager une personne handicapée va
être un handicap pour leur entreprise au
contraire mesdames et messieurs c'est
pas ça si a sil saent faire ce que que
vous attendez de lui ou d'elle ne
regardez pas son handicap regardez
d'abord la personne que c'est et à ce
moment-l vous l'engagez pour la personne
qu'il est ou qu'elle est et puis votre
entreprise elle est pas encore adaptée
pour cette personne en situation d'hicap
et ben c'est pas la peine d'attendre
demain matin 8h vous commencez vous vous
adaptez votre entreprise parce que c'est
normal c'est normal on fait partie du
monde ah oui quand je commence là je
suis obligé d'être passionné parce que
on fait partie de ce monde vous trouvez
que ça ne bouge pas assez vite
absolument ça bien sû ça bouge ass vite
et c'est vous qui avez sollicité cette
mission on vous l'a demandé Gilbert non
non non je rien sollicité du tout on
vous l' on vous l'a proposé on m'a
proposé vous avez été tout de suite
d'accord ou vous avez été rétissant par
rapport à la politique n'importe quel
parti en France m'aurait proposé cette
nomination sauf un parti de Corée du
Nord j'aurais dit oui j'aurais dit oui
parce que pour quel que soit l'étiquette
politique c'est ça que je voulez dire ou
l'étiquette n'est pas importante moi
l'Ance c'est la possibilité de pouvoir
faire alors ce qui est difficile moi
dans dans dans ma mission c'est c'est
toute la pression que j'ai sur la tête
de tous les jours des messages de
détresse des messages d'appel au secours
c'est très lourd à porter parce
qu'évidemment ils peuvent beaucoup plus
me parler directement qu'au ministre et
au secrétaire d'État parce que il y a
moins de filtre parce que il y a mon
site personnel et et c'est vrai que
c'est lourd à porter quand on sait qu'on
peut pas tout faire évidemment qu'on
peut pas tout faire on vous a reproché
d'être récupéré vous politiquement vous
avez eu peur peut-être vous-même d'être
récupéré politiquement sincèrement j'ai
peur moi j'ai peur de rien du tout euh
il y a des gens est dans le public qui
qui n'ont pas compris au début que que
je m'étais engagé et je voudrais que
dans le pays des droits de l'homme et
des libertés on comprennent que moi
aussi j'ai le droit à ma liberté et je
n'ai qu'un seul but mais qu'un seul but
c'est d'aider la cause des personnes
handicapés dont je fais partie ceux qui
sont engagés au côté de Nicolas Sarkozi
les artistes hein disent la plupart
qu'il est plus facile finalement d'être
à gauche quand on est artiste que que de
s'engager à droite senti ça que je
comprends pas quand on se dit de de
gauche c'est de bon ton mais pas de
l'autre côté alors moi ça m'énerve
beaucoup dans le sens où moi je suis
désolé personne à me donner de leçon
dans le sens où moi je viens d'un monde
ouvrier ok je viens d'un monde où mes
parents n'avaient rien du tout on avait
rien on avait pas de blé et je veux dire
que mes parents ils ne il ils ne
juraient que par la gauche mes parents
non n'ont rien eu aucune aide alors on
va pas me la ronter à moi ça va je
connais le film j'ai absolument rien
contre personne mais toute façon
l'important c'est pas d'être de gauche
ni d'être ou d'être de droite
l'important c'est surtout d'être sincère
et de parler avec son cœur et pas par
opportunisme et là j'ai une bonne
nouvelle mesames et messieurs c'est que
c'est certainement pas par opportunisme
dans le sens où j'ai pas attendu après
ça pour faire carrière donc il y a aucun
problème en plus c'est une mission
totalement bénévole et ouais ouais moi
je dis les choses telleles qu'elles sont
aut ne l'aurit pas fait voilà et Nicole
vous êtes dans ce combat je vois que
vous êtes complètement parti prenanteou
en fait je suis l'assistante de Gilbert
et je suis l'assistante dans tout j'ai
pas sectorisé notre travail parce que ça
a toujours été partie prenante
l'handicap dans la vie de Gilbert donc
elle ne fait que se confirmer Népal
porte beaucoup sur ses épaules c'est
vrai merci beaucoup à tous les deux mais
merci à vous moi ça m'a fait vraiment du
bien de m'ouvrir ce soir ben je suis sûr
nous tous de vous entendre avec cet
optimisme qui qui vous
caractérise pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous
et activez la
[Musique]
cloche